[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
RYAN BOYD: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Ryan
and Michael Show.
I'm Ryan Boyd.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I'm
Michael Manoochehri.
RYAN BOYD: And we're here today
to talk about preparing
your data for BigQuery.
So if you have any questions
throughout this little
discussion on preparing your
data and loading your data
into BigQuery, you can feel free
to ask them in the Google
Moderator that is available on
developers.google/com/live.
Hopefully, you're watching
it there.
And you can ask your questions,
and we'll save some
time for the end
to answer them.
Of course, if you have any other
questions after today or
you're not watching it live, you
can ask those questions on
Stack Overflow, and we'll
answer them there.
Or reach out to Michael or
myself on our Google+ handles
that you see on this page.
So looking forward to
hearing from you.
Now let's dive in.
So the first thing we want to
talk about is the data format.
What does your data need to look
like when you load your
data into BigQuery?
It's pretty simple.
It's a CSV-formatted file.
So here we can see three
lines of a CSV file.
This is actually data
representing the--
sorry.
Michael, do you remember
what this data was?
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN BOYD: Sorry.
It's been a little bit.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
That's right.
It looks like this might be
election data or maybe
natality data.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
So three rows of data
in a CSV file.
And we can see some of
our basic types here.
We have a strings.
We have ints.
We have floats.
And we have Boolean values.
Those are the main
types that you're
used to using in BigQuery.
And you just format a CSV file,
new line delimited.
You can quote your strings
and things like
that, but basic types.
And our goal through the rest
of the discussion here today
is how to prepare these
CSV files and
get these into BigQuery.
Now, we have developers
using a variety of
different data sources.
How you prepare your data and
load it into BigQuery often
really depends on your data
source that you're using.
So let's talk about the
types of data sources
that BigQuery users--
our developers or customers--
are using to load
into BigQuery.
It's all sort of transactional
data.
So the data sources commonly
used would make sense in a
BigQuery-style database are
transactional data, things
where the append-only style of
BigQuery works out well.
So web logs is one of
the most popular.
The standard Apache web blog,
various fields representing
information about the user
that's accessing the site,
what page that they're
accessing, the
host, things like that.
That type of data is fantastic
for BigQuery.
And those web logs can be things
that are on your own
local web server in your
local data center.
Or it can also be cloud-based
web logs.
So App Engine logs or logs from
other cloud-based platforms.
So that's one of the
most common.
But then you might actually have
some more specific types
of log files for mobile or
web application events.
So, for instance, on the Google
Play Store, there are a
number of applications there.
One of the top applications on
the Google Play Store actually
uses BigQuery to run
a lot of analysis.
And I'm not sure
what particular
data they're running.
But web application events and
mobile application events is a
really great type of data to
load into BigQuery and analyze
with BigQuery.
And you could often get lots of
traffic on the initial day
you launch on the Play Store.
And you can potentially get a
lot of customers immediately.
And you want to be able to track
how they're using your
product and going to use that
information to improve your
application that you're
offering.
Syslog-style data for
machine performance.
The range of different use
cases that developers use
BigQuery for is very diverse.
So we have people using it for
ad monetization, but also
people using it to monitor
their servers.
And that's what this one is
about-- syslog-style data
monitoring machine
performance.
We actually have a case study
that should be out soon that
really talks about how one of
our developers uses it to
monitor the performance of their
applications and the
machines that are hosting
those applications.
Then, of course, were Google
advertising click and
impression data, Sales
transaction records, all very
important types of transactional
data that is
great to load into BigQuery
for analysis.
And the last one I mention here
is App Engine data store.
So oftentimes, you may have
sensors in machines all around
the world, and you want to load
that data into BigQuery.
It's best to use the cloud to
really collect that data, and
App Engine's a great
way to do that.
So you can collect the data in
App Engine, put it into the
data store, and then take the
data out of the data store,
and load it into BigQuery
in batches.
And we'll talk about how we've
used some of our Google
technologies for doing
that here shortly.
So now I want to talk about the
process of loading data
into BigQuery.
The process of loading data
is pretty simple.
Your data is loaded by preparing
your data, uploading
it to Google Cloud Storage, and
then from Cloud Storage,
you're basically making a API
call to BigQuery and telling
it to ingest the data
from Cloud Storage.
It's a fairly simple process.
I will say that you can
technically skip the middle
part of this process here
and upload your
data directly to BigQuery.
We generally don't recommend
it because Cloud Storage is
really optimized.
All the APIs and tools around
Cloud Storage are really
optimized for handling
large files.
And so that's often the
great way to do it.
You get your large files into
Cloud Storage, and then you
let BigQuery retrieve them from
Cloud Storage as part of
its ingestion process.
And that's the least error-prone
way of doing this.
And so we've had developers
try to upload their files
directly to BigQuery, and
sometimes they just run into
some issues.
And those issues are usually
because they're uploading very
large files, and they're trying
to make a plain HTTP
request to upload those large
files and not taking advantage
of our resumable upload
feature that we have.
And the resumable upload
feature, if you're using the
resumable upload feature, I
think you should be able to
about the same reliability, even
if you skip Cloud Storage
in this process, uploading
directly to BigQuery.
Try it out.
Let us know what
you're seeing.
And we'd be happy to know if
there's great success in using
that resumable upload to upload
directly to BigQuery.
Our libraries support this.
And a lot of the libraries
support the ability to do
resumable uploads.
We don't yet have it super
well-documented on the
BigQuery side.
We're working on that.
But you can see the generic
library documentation on how
to do resumable uploads.
Now, the next thing we wanted to
talk about-- and I'm going
to turn over to Michael for
this-- is chunking your data,
breaking up your data into the
parts required for ingesting
it into BigQuery.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
So let's dive into it.
So as you know, BigQuery is used
for analyzing or asking
questions about massive
data sets.
But to get your data into
BigQuery, it's good to chunk
it into parts.
So BigQuery supports ingestion
or loading of both compressed,
with the gzip, or uncompressed
files.
Right now, the maximum size of
each file is 4 gigabytes.
But you can ingest large
batches of files.
You can ingest up to 500 files
in one load job as long as the
total job is under
100 gigabytes.
So anecdotally, I've run some
tests using some of the data
that we have internally.
And I've been able to ingest
upwards of 300 gigabytes of
uncompressed data in one load
job by first gzipping that
data and then ingesting it
into a single batch.
So you can actually put
in a lot of data
in one batch ingestion.
This is another advantage
to using the
Cloud Storage for ingesting.
You can ingest giant
batches that are
stored in Cloud Storage.
So it's really great.
Let us deal with the
infrastructure.
I think that's usually
a good lesson.
And so let's talk about speeding
up the data loading.
So I just told you that you
could ingest an enormous
amount of data in
one load job.
There's other ways that you
can even improve this
ingestion rate.
We actually let you ingest
two concurrent
ingestion jobs at a time.
And so you can have two-- these
huge batches-- two of
them in flight at
a single time.
And so you can do that,
two concurrent.
And we can also allow you
to do 1,000 per day.
So you can do the math.
If you're ingesting hundreds of
gigabytes of data, you can
ingest 1,000 of them a day.
And so you can get a massive
amount of data ingested into
BigQuery in one go.
RYAN BOYD: Now, some people try
with that 1,000 per day to
stream data in.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: And generally,
BigQuery is not designed right
now for streaming-style
ingestion.
You can still upload and do many
ingestion jobs per hour
and have sort of near
real-time data.
But you're not going
to get down to the
second data quite yet.
If it's something you're
interested in-- yeah,
definitely let us know.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah, it's
still a batch process.
We'd love to hear it.
Actually, Ryan touched
on this earlier.
Some people are using the data
store to collect data.
So that's a very highly
available, performant way to
collect data in real time and
then using a batch job from
there to put the data
into BigQuery.
So there's other ways
you can handle that.
RYAN BOYD: And one thing I will
say on the job style,
we've been asked this question
a number of times on Stack
Overflow and other things, is
whether when the job fails--
in some cases, you have
a misformatted line or
something like that.
If the job fails, does it
ever partially complete?
And the answer is no.
When a job fails with BigQuery,
that job is
completely failed.
We haven't updated
your data at all.
So you just retry that job
without ever having to worry
about potential error
conditions or
anything along the way.
And one other thing, actually,
I should say that we kind of
forgot as we were preparing for
this but I think is really
important is, at times, your
data's not perfect.
You're loading data in, and it's
not absolutely perfect.
There's some formatting issues
or what have you.
You can actually specify kind
of your error tolerance when
you load data into BigQuery.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: Either using the
BigQ client or using the
client libraries when you create
your job JSON object.
You can basically say I can have
up to, say, 50 lines of
data that are bad.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
Misformatted or have
bad encoding or
something like that.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
So often, you'll want to kind
of do that as your first
experimenting.
You'll want to set a little bit
higher threshold as your
first experiment.
And as you get more and more
data into BigQuery and you get
confidence in your data format
and your collection
techniques, then you
can actually change
that and back off.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: When you're
dealing with huge file
sizes, when you're dealing
terabyte file sizes or
gigabyte files sizes, the
chances of having a bad line
because of something that
your output writer
dealt with is high.
So this is a great
feature for that.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
Exactly.
So fantastic.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Cool.
So let's talk about designing
a BigQuery schema.
So if you're from the relational
database world,
you're probably used to what we
call normalization of data,
which is to keep everything in
one place and just have one
copy of it.
So an example we have here, this
is a relational database
of two tables, one with parents
and one with a person.
So a person generally
has two parents.
And in this type schema,
the parents will have
a key like an ID.
And basically all the data
will be in one place.
So your birth record will
be in one place.
And your parents will be a
single record in a parents
table, your father and mother.
So this is a normalized table.
So BigQuery likes to have
denormalized data,
non-relational data.
So the idea will be to have
a record with every bit of
information flattened.
So all the data that you saw
on the other table will be
flattened into a
single record.
So, in practice, this means
there can be redundancy and
can be null values, what
we call sparsity.
And this is the kind
of table that
BigQuery actually accepts.
So when you have relational
data, what you want to do is
flatten it out into
a single record
denormalized table for BigQuery.
RYAN BOYD: Actually, I want to
say in terms of the advantages
or the reasons you're taught in
school to always normalize
your data into the multiple
tables that Michael just
talked about here, one of the
real advantages of that is
just maintaining consistency
of your data.
So if you update information
about a parent in this case,
that all their children see
the same parent metadata.
The parent change their age
or something like that.
All of the children records
reflect that, and you never
have inconsistent
sources there.
But with a BigQuery-style
database, where it's sort of
an append-only transactional
data and you're really trying
to do an analysis, the
consistency isn't a problem
there because you've had the
consistency through the life
cycle of the data as the
data's being created.
But then as you're analyzing it,
the flat structure is much
better for performance.
And you don't lose anything by
not having that consistency.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
That's great.
So building off that, another
technique for BigQuery is to
actually shard your data.
So by taking, say--
in this example, we're taking
birth records from different
years and placing them into
different tables.
There's a lot of advantages
to doing this.
First, for example, BigQuery
actually is priced by the
amount of data you query.
So by sharding your data, you
can actually make your queries
as efficiently priced
as possible.
This is also a good way to just
make your queries more
manageable.
So you can say I want to deal
with data from 2011 and have
the data sharded there.
So this is a great way logically
to organize your
data into tables, into these
kind of denormalized flattened
tables that we talked about.
RYAN BOYD: And, of course,
if you're trying to query
multiple years of data, you
can just do simple union
queries to do that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Exactly.
So we support that
as well, yeah.
So great.
So we talked to you a little
bit about designing these
tables and how to ingest data.
But let's talk about tools
for data preparation.
What are the actual tools
you can use to get
the data into BigQuery?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, so there
are a variety of
different tools here.
And it goes all over
the board.
A lot of is based off of what
your experience is.
what the source of data is,
where is the data being
collected, and things like
that, what tools
you're going to choose.
But we'll give you an idea of
some of the tools that we've
used and some of the tools that
our customers have used
with BigQuery.
So there's the App Engine
MapReduce and Pipelines API.
We're gonna talk about this
a little bit more later.
But App Engine MapReduce is
an implementation of the
MapReduce algorithms
in App Engine.
It's pure App Engine
implementation.
And we've used it.
And we've heard others using it
to great success in running
sort of large jobs to
transform data.
And then, of course, the
Pipelines API, which is
actually what MapReduce is
built in part on top of.
And the Pipelines API basically
allows you to create
a dependency tree of jobs,
executions, so kind of a
workflow of the various
processes that
are going into play.
And again, running
on App Engine.
And it's very helpful for doing
things where you we want
to process a bunch of files and
then load it into BigQuery
if the files processed
correctly.
And we'll see an example
here shortly.
There are also, of course,
commercial ETL tools.
There's an entire industry out
there preparing tools to allow
you to prepare your data.
And these tools are--
there's a wide variety
of them.
The licensing and the
way that they're
structured is different.
Some are actually even
open source models.
But I'm going to talk about
Pervasive a little bit more.
And then we also have
Informatica and Talend, who
have all integrated with
BigQuery to allow it to be
really easy for you to load your
data into Cloud Storage
and ingest it into BigQuery.
And then, of course,
our favorite--
the UNIX command-line.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We've
rediscovered the UNIX
command-line.
RYAN BOYD: Yes, rediscovered
the UNIX command-line.
Oftentimes, there are simple
UNIX command-line tools that
you can use to prepare
your data.
This is especially great if it's
a one-time load job that
you're doing and not something
that you're regularly
scheduling.
These tools are pretty
fantastic.
And we'll give you some hints
as to how we've used them.
And then, of course, if you have
XML, use a bit of code.
We don't have too much on
this in the rest of the
presentation, but I will say
Wikipedia provides their
revision history.
So basically, all the revisions
that have happened
to every single page in
Wikipedia, about 450 million
rows, you can download
that as one XML file.
And if I'm recalling correctly,
I think it was like
130 gigabytes compressed
or something.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Pretty massive.
RYAN BOYD: Massive XML file.
You're going to want to use a
streaming-based parser or a
SAX-based parser for that XML.
The lxml library in Python I've
found to be very helpful
for doing that.
So check that out.
So the commercial side,
here's an example.
It's a screenshot
from Pervasive's
RushAnalyzer product.
And we've worked with them
to integrate BigQuery.
And you can see in a very visual
fashion and create this
in a very visual fashion a
workflow for loading your data
into BigQuery.
So in this case, they're
actually taking data from a
on-premise HFS file system, and
joining that data together
with data from a MySQL database
that's either
in-house or in the cloud, and
bringing that all together and
joining it even with some,
I believe, FAT files, and
selecting only particular fields
after they do that
join, selecting only the fields
that they require, and
then writing that out to
BigQuery and using Cloud
Storage as kind of the
intermediate step.
But--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I think
these guys are doing that
denormalization and flattening
you described.
Or we described earlier.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
That's actually all what
this joining is, is the
denormalization process of
pre-joining the data before
loading it into the BigQuery.
So it's a great tool for doing
that type of thing.
And you can do it in this
visual style workflow.
The other commercial ETL tools,
the Informaticas and
Talends provide similar style
of creating your workflows.
And I know with Pervasive, when
you build that workflow,
you can execute it locally.
But you can also distribute the
job to actually run it in,
say, one of your local
on-premise data centers or
even run it in the cloud and
have this job really scale out
to a lot of machines running
this load job and schedule it
and that sort of thing.
It provides all that power and
flexibility but with this nice
GUI front end to it.
So that's pretty powerful.
But sometimes you don't need
that level of power.
And that's where the UNIX
command-line tools come in.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN BOYD: Here's a row data,
which I do know where this row
of data came from.
This is the campaign
finance data.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Ah, yes.
RYAN BOYD: So this is--
the government actually
publishes--
the US Government publishes
donations to
various political campaigns.
So you can see here this
is a donation that I
made in 2008 for $50.
It's in that record.
And it's all public data that
the government's publishing.
So one thing that you'll
notice here that I've
highlighted on this data is
the year and the date.
So 2008-10-19 is when I
made this donation.
Exactly two weeks after my
birthday, apparently, I made
this donation for $50.
But the thing is, BigQuery
doesn't handle date formats
very well like this.
I mentioned some of the
basic date formats--
sorry--
the basic field formats
that BigQuery
provides in its schema.
And it's things like ints
and strings and floats.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Booleans.
RYAN BOYD: And Booleans.
Yeah, exactly, so these
various formats.
But dates currently don't have
a special format in BigQuery.
We rely on integers.
And this is actually quite
familiar with those UNIX geeks
out there because time since
epoch, or January 1, 1970, is
a very common way to keep track
of time in UNIX tools.
And so we use that in
BigQuery as well.
And you can sort your
data based off of
that time since epoch.
And it's really easy once
you get your data in.
But some people have a little
bit of a challenge doing the
conversion to get the data in.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: This
is a very common
data conversion issue.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, and something
we'll probably resolve in the
core product.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN BOYD: And there are
actually functions in BigQuery
when you're querying the data
to convert that time since
epoch back out to a more human
representative of a form.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yeah, exactly.
RYAN BOYD: But anyway, so
here's our basic data.
You have the time
in 2008-10-19.
And we want to convert it into
a time that looks like this,
which is that time
since epoch.
So that's the number of seconds
since January 1, 1970.
And so to do that conversion is
really, really simple on a
command-line tool.
And I never would have known
this without the web.
Google is your friend when
trying to do these things.
I'm not that big of
an expert in awk.
But here is an awk command.
Now, you'll notice that I'm on
my machine, logged onto my
machine here, campaign
finance directory.
And what I'm doing first is
doing kind of a streaming
unzip from gunzip and piping
that output to GNU's awk.
And then basically what it's
doing here is replacing the
dashes in the date with spaces
and then passing that time as
a string time into the mktime
function to make a time object
out of that.
And that becomes our int that's
the time since epoch.
And we're substituting column 10
of our original source file
with that time and printing it
all out, and then again,
piping it out to gzip to
compress the data again.
So there's a really
large source file.
We can actually only decompress
a couple lines at a
time, whatever's in the buffer
here, so very powerful tool
with just UNIX command-line.
The other UNIX command-line tool
that we should talk about
that's pretty powerful is
something to deal with that
4-gigabyte chunk that BigQuery
allows for currently.
So your file size on each file
can be up to 4 gigabytes.
And you sometimes want to split
your source file into
those 4-gigabyte chunks.
And you can do that.
Let's say you have a source file
that's 12 gigabytes, and
you need this less than 4
gigabytes or less than or
equal to chunk, you
can use split.
And this is how you do it.
It's really simple.
You're saying split -C. And -C
is making sure that it doesn't
split on anything other than a
new line so you don't get a
partial line of data.
But then it's writing out 4
gigs of data per chunk.
And you have your source
file here.
And it will just create a series
of other files, which
will be numbered based off of
their position in that series
up to-- in this case, it
would be three separate
files with four gigs.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I use
this command all the time.
What's great about it is
it's easy to script.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So you
script it, and you put it into
your ingestion job, and
it's really great.
RYAN BOYD: All right.
Now I'm going to hand this back
over to Michael to chat a
little about a project that
we've been working on recently
to load 6 terabytes of data or 2
terabytes compressed of data
into BigQuery.
Michael.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
So like as Ryan said, we've been
working on this really
fun project.
This is kind of putting
everything we just talked
about in practice.
It's a study in loading 6
terabytes of data into
BigQuery using App Engine.
So this has been really great.
We're are looking at Wikipedia
page views.
So Wikipedia publishes
hourly the page
views of all the pages.
And this is a huge-- since 2008,
I think, is the data
that we're looking.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
It starts at the end of 2007,
beginning of 2008.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Exactly.
RYAN BOYD: I think we
skipped the last
couple of days of 2007.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
OK, you're right.
So we don't have all of it.
But the data we have is
6 terabytes of data.
And this is split up into
thousands of files of, I
think, hundreds of
megabytes each.
I think they're-- compressed,
they are
something like 100 megs.
RYAN BOYD: Anywhere
between 30--
you can actually see from the
size of the files how much
Wikipedia has grown,
even since 2008.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes, yes.
RYAN BOYD: Because the file
sizes increase, I think, from
30 megabytes compressed
up to about 100.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes.
RYAN BOYD: I think there were
like 60,000 files or something
crazy like that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's an
enormous amount of data.
RYAN BOYD: Right.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So what
we're doing is using App
Engine for its ability to
distribute tasks across a lot
of instances automatically.
So what we're actually doing--
here's an example of what
we're actually doing.
The original schema of these
Wikipedia page jumps looks
something like this
on the left side.
So there's a language, the title
of the Wikipedia page,
the amount of page views it's
gotten in the particular hour
that that file pertains to, and
the amount of bytes in the
page, which is also great,
because you can see how that
changes over time as well.
So this is a really interesting
data set.
What we want to do is take this
data, this raw data, and
put it into a BigQuery's table
that looks like the
schema on the right.
So what we're doing is we're
doing some of that sort of
date/time transformation that
Ryan talked about earlier.
And we're breaking down your
month and day to make our
queries simpler.
RYAN BOYD: And on the date/time
transformation, we
don't actually show it here.
But the files are actually named
based off of the year,
month, day, and hour
of the request.
So there's one file for every
hour since the end of 2007.
And so we're taking the info
from the file name and
actually combining that and
joining that with the rest of
the record that's in the file.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yeah, exactly.
And we're actually parsing that
out and the first five
fields are based on
that information.
And also the Wikipedia project
is actually something we pull
from the title.
That's could be Wikipedia
itself, and I think there's
other Wikipedia projects,
not the main
Wikipedia, but other things.
So we don't put the language
in there as well.
We parse the title.
And then we take the page
views and the bytes
transferred just as integers and
put this into the table.
RYAN BOYD: And actually on the
date/time stuff, originally we
actually put the date/time
literally as just a string.
And it was actually quite easy
to work with as a string if
you knew some things about
regular expressions.
You could do the sorts and the
searches and all with the
strings because you were using
the regular expression to
convert it to integers
for that process.
But eventually we figured out
not everyone every time they
run a query--
even though regular expressions
are super fast,
even over hundreds of millions
of rows of data with BigQuery,
or billions of rows of data with
BigQuery, not everyone
wants to do that regular
expression every time they're
running the query.
So that's why we did some kind
of pre-analysis here and
separated out--
put the date/time since epoch
and then the year, month, day,
and hour just to make it easier
to query, even though
it would have worked
otherwise.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
It's true.
It's super convenient.
Imagine running a query
about noon.
So give me all the pages that
were looked at at noon.
And that's an easy query to do
with this kind of format.
One thing I forgot to mention
is we're also sharding this
data, as we mentioned earlier,
into months.
So every bit of data
is sharded into
a table of a month.
So we can look at the
month itself.
And if we want to look at more
months, we could run a union
query with BigQuery.
We could even look at the entire
data set month after
month by just specifying the
table name in our queries.
So it makes it really
convenient.
I think this is a really good
strategy for this type of data
and this amount of data.
But how did we get
the data in?
So that's the really
interesting part.
We decided to use App Engine and
the Pipelines API, which
we mentioned earlier.
So what's great about Pipelines,
as Ryan mentioned,
is it allows you to build a
workflow and distribute the
work of ingesting all of these
files into multiple instances
on App Engine pretty
much automatically.
It lets you just worry about
the code itself rather than
actually distributing this
across a bunch of task queues.
This has been really
convenient.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
So on the distributed nature
of it, it's been fantastic.
So we have--
we're basically breaking this
down by month and only
processing a month
at the time.
And depending on the number of
days in a given month, 720 to
740 files for every month, and
we're distributing that
across, I believe in our latest
configuration, about
100 App Engine instances to
have all of those 100 App
Engine instances process this
data simultaneously.
And it just speeds this up to
what would have been a process
that I probably would
take like half
a year on my desktop.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: We can have
App Engine do it in
a much faster way.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: The
Pipelines API is great too
because it provides a sort of
control panel, or status page
actually, of what's going on.
So you can actually follow the
workflow as it's happening and
kind of check on the status of
individual, let's say, leaves
on the workflow tree and see
what each one is doing.
So it's been really
convenient.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, you can see
here that the children listed
on the bottom right here, that's
the children of this
process month.
And we can click
on any of them.
We actually did.
You'll see some of these.
I don't know if you can
see it in the video.
It might be a little
too small.
But some of these are calling
Pipelines called
Process File Pipeline.
And that's actually doing the
full transformation and
processing the file.
But some of the other
pipelines are
called Return File Name.
That's in the case that we
already processed the file and
are just trying to make sure
that it gets included in the
upcoming ingestion job.
So we kept track of the things
that we were doing and stored
that in the App Engine
data store so that
when we actually do--
if we do have an error, if one
of the files is bad, or
something like that,
we can rerun
this without any problems.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
and it's been great.
The other thing is sometimes
when you're dealing with this
many files, you may have a
corrupted file in the source.
There's all kinds of things
that can happen.
So adding this kind of check on
have you processed the file
is a really good
best practice.
RYAN BOYD: yeah, so these are
basically just broke up by
month, processed all the files
in that given month, and then
went off and called a big
query ingestion job.
And our queues--
this is built on top
of the task queues.
Our queues for calling BigQuery
ingestion, basically
we're configuring them such that
we're only running the
two ingestion job simultaneously
on BigQuery to
go by that quota limit.
And we can--
sorry.
We're running those two
simultaneously.
But in the case sometimes that
we mess up, we're actually
detecting failures and rerunning
the task in case
there are any failures.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And
Ryan, remind me.
I think each month has something
like 720 files.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, that's right.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So to
adjust an entire month we
actually split that into two
batches of like 350 or
something like that of files
in multiple batches.
So it's a great way to
get most of that.
We can almost ingest an entire
month's in one batch, which is
pretty remarkable.
It's quite a lot of data.
RYAN BOYD: All right.
So I think that's really about
it for today's episode.
You've seen Michael and Ryan's
tips for how to work with
BigQuery and getting your
data into BigQuery.
And hopefully this helps
you a little bit as you
load your own data.
Let's give a quick overview of
what we discussed today, and
then we'll get into your
questions that you have on the
Google Moderator.
And so we've talked about
denormalization being your
friend, talked about
sharding your data.
If you need to transform your
data, you can use a variety of
different tools-- commercial
tools, App Engine, or your
favorite UNIX commands.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN BOYD: And now it's time
for your questions.
Let's see what questions exist
over on our Google Moderator.
And it actually looks like we
have one person live on the
Hangout as well.
So if the person that's live on
the Hangout can introduce
themselves and talk a little bit
about what they're doing
with BigQuery or what they'd
like to do with BigQuery.
And then feel free to ask any
questions that you have.
Hello?
I believe you're muted
right now.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN BOYD: There we go.
I think we're hearing you now.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
All right.
How's it going?
Good to see you.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Yeah, so I'm the person
in the Hangout then.
And actually, I'm not
doing currently
anything with big data.
I'm fascinated by it.
I'm working with qualitative
data for my PhD thesis, which
is badly structured.
Basically, you're doing text
analysis and things like that.
And I find it inspiring what
can be done with this
processing and analysis
of date.
Now, the amount of data which
I have I could possibly
process on any recent
mobile phone.
But there are--
in my other life, I'm working
as a project manager in data
center project management.
And I find it intriguing to
apply some principles which
are used to analyze qualitative
data with all the
data that is available in all
those files loading and
whatever information in
larger organizations.
So it's a form of data mining,
but which escapes the typical
data mining situation.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
BigQuery's really great for this
kind of taking data out
of silos, joining them, and
then running aggregates.
We actually have some customers
doing this.
This is a great use case because
it handles such a huge
amount of data.
It's sometimes the only tool
that can handle this in an
ad-hoc way to let you
run these queries
in an ad-hoc way.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
We actually have a colleague
of ours, Katherine.
Michael, Katherine, and I are
all speaking at upcoming
Strata conferences between
London and New York.
And Katherine's working
on preparing her talk.
And she's actually, I believe,
keynoting at
the Strata in London.
And she's really looking at,
from a data journalism
perspective, how to source
a bunch of data.
A lot of the data,
you actually--
you're looking at a subset of
data and trying to come up
with a bigger meaning out
of that subset of data.
And you really--
a lot of the work is really
trying to find all the data
that would possibly explain that
small subset that you're
looking at.
And it's a lot of hard times.
But hopefully, some of the tips
that we gave you here
today will at least, once you
can get your hands on that
data, help you prepare it and
kind of denormalize it and get
it into BigQuery if you guys
decide to do that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: This use
case you brought up of text
analysis is really
interesting.
We actually do some of that
on our team as well.
One thing to know about BigQuery
is the maximum record
size is 64K for any
single record.
However, it's great for things
like n-gram analysis or word
count analysis.
So this is the kind of thing
where maybe a MapReduce job to
find, say, word counts per
document and then put all of
that data into BigQuery.
That's a really good use of
BigQuery, especially when you
have tons of data.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
And we actually have some
example data sets doing that
already, like n-gram data set
and then a Wikipedia data set.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
RYAN BOYD: I think the
n-gram is from
Google Books, I believe.
Sorry.
Not Wikipedia.
n-gram and--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Shakespeare.
RYAN BOYD: And Shakespeare.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: Yes.
So we have some of the example
data sets doing that.
We're actually working with the
Wikipedia stuff soon to
basically take all of the text
in Wikipedia and make that
into n-grams just to see what
words are most commonly
appearing, when words first
appear, and things like that.
Some fun analysis
on text data.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
One last thing is the other
thing that's really great
about BigQuery is that
it's an API.
And it's really easy to
integrate into, say, web
applications.
Any kind of application,
actually.
You ask questions, send
queries to it via API.
We also have tools.
We have a browser tool and
a command-line tool.
But you can actually write code
with this very simply.
So it's all kind of built in
together with the API.
So it makes application
processing super easy.
You can build JavaScript apps
in just a few lines of code.
You can use App Engine.
And you can build a very
powerful application in very
little code.
So it's great for some of the
things you're talking about.
MALE SPEAKER: Where is the best
place to get started?
So I'm more a casual programmer,
if at all.
So I can do some stuff in Python
or Java or processing
to do little things,
visualizations, but it's--
this is really old
school, yes?
What I'm doing.
So if I want to go into the big
data examples or just fool
around with it, where
do I start?
Is there any place where you can
get a step-by-step example
to get you started?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
In BigQuery, I think I would
start out in BigQuery, I
believe we have a step-by-step
getting started guide to
working on some of the
public data samples.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
RYAN BOYD: So the public data
samples in BigQuery, you can
actually run queries against
up to 100 gigabytes a day
worth of queries for free
without putting down your
credit card.
So you can start by looking at
some of that existing data and
not deal with the process of
loading your own data.
But you can see what types of
queries that you can perform.
I've had a lot of fun
looking at the
natality data, for instance.
That's US birth statistics
since 1969, I believe.
And basically there's a line for
every single birth in the
US that's occurred in
that time period.
And you have some interesting
things like in Ohio in 2003 if
you look at the babies born
there to mothers who smoked
cigarettes versus didn't smoke
cigarettes, the babies born to
mothers who smoked cigarettes
were half a pound lighter than
the babies who had mothers that
didn't smoke cigarettes.
And you find interesting
bits of data.
And that's actually what
BigQuery is really great for,
is this ad-hoc analysis in an
aggregate fashion on large
chunks of data.
So I would try that out, just
play around with that data.
In terms of visualization, you
can actually see some of the
demos from ClickView and BEAM,
who have built visualizations
already on top of
that data set.
And then use something like
Google Apps Script.
In about 70 lines of code, you
can visualize data that comes
from BigQuery queries in Google
Apps Script inside a
spreadsheet.
And then do graphs and pivot
tables and that sort of thing.
And if you're a friend of Excel
instead, we have the big
great connector for Excel that
we just launched a week or two
ago that provides similar
functionality and a really
easy way to get that.
So you don't really need coding
experience right now.
We aim ourselves as an API with
BigQuery for developers.
But to get started in trying
it out, you don't actually
need heavyweight coding
experience.
So on the BigQuery side,
I would check some
of that stuff out.
App Engine MapReduce, I believe,
has a Getting Started
like word count sort of
MapReduce that you can run.
That's going to be a little bit
heavier coding a little
bit heavier algorithms
understanding
what's going on there.
But hopefully, between those
two data sources.
So in BigQuery just go to
developers.google.com/bigquery.
And there's a Getting
Started guide there.
And you can try it out.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah, the
one you mentioned, the browser
tool, so we have the BigQuery
browser tool, that's all
through the web browser.
And you can run some of
these queries for
free by signing up.
So, yeah, just go to the Getting
Started guide on
developers.google.com/bigquery.
RYAN BOYD: Yep.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: That's the
best place to get started.
MALE SPEAKER: Great,
great, great.
RYAN BOYD: Well, thank
you for stopping by.
It doesn't look like we actually
have any other
questions in the Moderator
currently.
So I think the Ryan and
Michael Show is about
ready to sign off.
But thank you all for joining.
It's been a pleasure.
And hopefully, we'll
continue this.
And let us know your feedback
on Google+.
Let us know your technical
questions on Stack Overflow.
And we're excited to
keep on seeing how
you're using BigQuery.
Thanks.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
All right.
Bye, everyone.
RYAN BOYD: Goodbye.
MALE SPEAKER: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]